I think people say I look a bit like a
queen in this outfit and people call me
your majesty people come up when they
curtsy it's almost like living two lives
really let's commence
[Music]
I'm Ella slack and I'm the queen
standing I've done it for over 30 years
now anything that the Queen does is
rehearsed if it's just going to a town
hall or opening a hospital I've probably
been a stand-in queen definitely more
than 50 times a stand-in is not a look a
lie I don't look like the Queen but I'm
the same sort of stature and hyped I'm
about virtually five-foot the Queen's
about 5 foot 2 but I live at royal court
on Queens promenade in Royal Ramsey in
the Isle of Man and the Queen lives in
Buckingham Palace in London I drive a
Ford gear automatic car the Queen has
been seen to drive Range Rovers and most
of the time she's in a trophy driven car
or in a carriage well it started because
I was at the BBC and the producer who
was doing the Cenotaph came to see me
and said that the Queen had sent a
message to say when she stood at the
Cenotaph this Sun was in her eyes and so
could we do anything about it well I
said to him would you like me to come
and stand in the position for you
because all the stage managers were 6
footmen and then that led on to other
things I went in her royal carriage and
rode on the boat up to the Tower of
London and then there will be the State
Opening of Parliament
I've never been allowed to sit on on the
throne in the House of Lords I have to
lurk above it it's a very strict rule if
I'm in a carriage or a car I will wave
you know it's like that
like that
the events that I've been helping with
events that are transmitted worldwide in
millions of people again to watch guy
look afterwards and watch the programs
going out and I'll see her there and
think I did it for you
[Music]
my name is Cecilia Chan people said I
bought Chinese food to America
Duras child was French since alechem
broad training
[Music]
this is all my sisters sesame in 1959 I
came to San Francisco visiting my sister
Sophie you live the edge of Chinatown
the first time I noticed the food I said
it is a Chinese food my scissors are yes
I look at the menu
ciaossu egg foo yung I'm original yo
Shanghai and I said I don't remember
we tested any of this in China so my
sister said this a American Chinese food
I decided I want to introduce my Chinese
food to USA I opened the bedroom in 1960
decent menu with the mayor Moscone the
customer my goodness the food tastes a
total different a lot of differences and
we never seen before we had hot and sour
soup the letters come the parse ticker
ticking down I was the first one served
in several seconds I didn't create it
but are you introduce that to American
and now everybody has it
I met Ellis Horner she came to the
Mandalay and one thing I know
I'm Ellis waters and I'm the owner of
Chez Panisse restaurant
I've known Cecilia almost 50 years
cecilius restaurant was incredibly
important and so many people came there
and learned and opened Chinese
restaurants or taught cooking you won
the junior youth so this way all the
Jews come all her food is very delicious
and if it is a little strange
she'll tell you a story about it and
you'll want to try it and every time I
have a meal with Cecilia I learned
something I don't get all the credit
but I said I did something people always
said before they see in the menu our
same American don't like it
I said good food is good food there's a
matter of your American and Chinese you
vocal fool I think everybody would like
it don't you say
you
[Music]
[Applause]
I've been told that there's no spot for
a woman in this sport I've been
physically assaulted in the Kate but I
didn't let any of that stop me
sometimes the fight is outside of the
ring I'm squeezie Valentine and I'm the
first and only cut woman in MMA what we
do is we rap the fighters hands before
they fight and we take care of them
between rounds if there's any bleeding
we stop it there's any swelling we take
it away pretty much the cut man motto is
to give them that one round that they
needed to win
I saw my first live MMA fight
and it was just such a cool experience
and I wanted to be a part of that arena
as much as I could I talked to the
promoter and asked him what jobs are
were he told me that my option was to be
a ring girl I had to wear the tiniest
string bikini
it was super uncomfortable to be wearing
that in front of all these people that
was not a fit for me I saw the fighters
get their hands wrapped and I
immediately got butterflies in my
stomach and I knew that was what I was
supposed to be a part of
I would drive 60 miles one way to gyms
and I would voluntarily sit there in rap
fighters hands for their sparring
sessions just a sacrifice of doing it
for so long without getting any income
out of it was really really hard I was a
single mother of two young boys and
still trying to be a cut woman rapping
hands is more than just putting gauze
around a hand if you do not wrap a
fighter's hands correctly then their
hands will break you need to wrap
hundreds and hundreds of hands to be
considered great I brought my kids hands
around my pears hands I brought my
friends hands I would wrap as many hands
as I could possibly find it took me
years to feel like I got it down my
first paying gig was wsof world series
of fighting in 2010 after four years of
doing it for free in 2014
I was added to the roster of UFC
becoming UFC is the Ultimate Fighting
Championship it is the most famous stage
in the world it's like the Olympics of
MMA and now I travel all over the world
being a cut woman for the UFC
[Applause]
during my journey of being a coven I had
a lot of ups and downs my kids are a
huge reason why I do all this they can
see me you know not giving up and in the
end hitting my goal and that's what
carried me through ten years of it you
know it's just that desire inside of
like just going to going I understand
what the fighter has to go through to
get into the cage we both had to fight
to get our spot in the ring I set the
record for the lowest limbo of a 25
inches in 2010 very proud of that
my name is Jamaica Campbell and I am a
world-class level dancer
[Music]
I'm originally from Trinidad and Tobago
which is also where limbo dance
originated it was a dance at wakes to
symbolize entering from one life to
another now today is literally
everywhere I got into the art of limbo
at the age of 14 my grandmother was a
limbo dancer
my mother was a little dancer and it's
only right that I live with the answer I
had to carry on that legacy not only for
my family but also for my culture as
well physically I am very flexible I do
my daily stretches I can't really feel
normal stretches so I have to like
create my own so where I would really
feel the stretching my legs
I get a little crazy sometimes for sure
[Music]
in order to make it under 8.5 inches I
have to hold my breath in order to
contort my body to make it under the bar
at the same time I have to think about
my arms I have to think about my
positioning I move side to side just to
show that I'm still suspended I start to
move actually physically under the bar
and that's pretty much when I made it so
let the air out and that's when I will
get up it's very very very hard to do
the pain that I feel during practicing
and pushing myself that comes with it
but that's one of the things that really
drew me to limbo it was something that I
couldn't do easily I love the challenge
me making it under this bar perfectly
every time
it means the absolute world I pretty
much limbo any and everywhere I've been
on America's Got Talent
twice I've been on The Ellen DeGeneres
Show I've been on The Late Late Show
with James Corden when I see people's
reactions and how appreciative they are
of my ability to do this is just amazing
I absolutely love them both I love
everything about it
people think that limbo was just for fun
for Trinidadians like myself is really a
big part of our culture I feel like
that's where my job comes in to really
show you this is more than just a fun
little activity
you